Being on forgetful to entertain
strangers for thereby some have
entertained angels unawares.
This is a commentary from Matthew Henry,
who is a nonconformist minister and
author,
cheerful and obliging.
Manners in showing kindness are great,
ornaments to piety or are condescending.
Lord Vouch,
safest,
not personal visits to us,
yet still by his spirit.
He stands at the door and knocks.
When we are inclined to open,
he deigns to enter by his gracious
constellations.
He provides a rich feast of which we
partake with him.
This is from revelations 3:20.
Behold,
I stand at the door and knock.
If any man hear my voice and open the
door,
I will come into him and will sup with
him and he with me.
Well,
the hyperlink nature of those quotes is
quite obvious.
There's 10 or 15 things being said at
the same time,
right?
One is a reference to the idea that if
you ask for something,
it will be given to you.
Right?
It was a very strange idea,
but I like that idea a lot and I believe
my,
in my experience,
that has been true.
If it was that I wanted what I was
asking for because that's the real
issue,
right,
because the question is if you want
something,
what does it mean to want it and what it
means is to sacrifice whatever is
necessary to get it because otherwise
you don't want it,
and so there's an equation here and I'm
not claiming it's ultimate accuracy,
but the equation is something like you
don't want it unless you're willing to
sacrifice for it and if you don't want
it,
you're not going to get it because
you're scattered.
But if you do want at any make the
proper sacrifices,
then God only knows what might happen
and that's a c.
One of the things I really like about
the existential philosophers is their
emphasis on personal responsibility.
You know that many of them had an
emphasis on the role that people had in
shaping their own destiny.
The exits for the existentialists,
and I think this was a consequence of
the religious substructure,
of,
of philosophical thinking.
It was self evident that life was tragic
and bitter,
but and then fair enough,
but that isn't where it ended.
The next issue was,
well,
there are better ways,
better and worse ways of dealing with
that,
and the better way of dealing with the
fact that life is tragic and better is
to
pause it,
the self you could be and live
authentically in relationship to that
and then the next issue and some.
This is something kierkegaard talked
about,
particularly when he talked about the
necessity of being a knight of faith,
is that the thing is,
and this is I think part of the light
part of life that's the intractable
adventure.
No one can take the adventure of life
away from you,
that they can't do it with good advice,
for example,
because no one can demonstrate to you
that if you straighten out a name at
what you want and make the proper
sacrifices that your life will turn out
in the manner that you might want it to
turn out.
It isn't in anyone else's purview to
make that judgment.
The only person that can possibly figure
that out is you.
It's something that can't be stolen from
you.
I would say it's your destiny.
It's a destiny that cannot be stolen
from you and you can forgo it.
You can say,
well,
I'm not willing to put in the effort
because what if I fail?
Well,
first of all,
if you don't put in the effort,
you will fail because life is hard and
it takes everything out of you to do it
properly so you will fail and if you
make the proper sacrifices,
you might fail.
That's why I like the ambiguity and the
story of Cain and Abel because we're
never really told why God rejects canes
offerings.
There's hands that came maybe isn't
doing as good a job as he should,
and he certainly gets bitter about it,
but there's no smoking pistol.
It doesn't say,
well,
Cain is a bad guy.
He made terrible sacrifices,
so god rejected him.
You never know.
Cain might've been working pretty damn
hard and things still didn't work out
for them,
and I think that ambiguity is
appropriate in the story because that
ambiguity ambiguity is in life.
You'd be.
You'd be a fool to say that everything
always works out for everyone if they
just do things right.
I mean,
I think that's a very,
that's a very careless thing to say,
given how much tragedy and catastrophe
there is in the world and how much of it
seems to be undeserved,
but that still has very little bearing I
think on,
on,
on your own individual adventure and the
necessity for
the necessity for opening the door to
who you could be and,
and the necessity to do that.
Seriously.
And I do believe and I think I,
I think that's why this most impossible
of versus you know,
knock and the door will open.
Why that's believable is that I have
never met anyone who couldn't
hypothesize a better them in some
manner.
All they had to do is ask.
It's like,
well,
how could you be better?
Thank well here's three ways.
It's like,
it's no problem,
right?
You can think about that no time flat.
Maybe it's small ways,
but you can almost always at least think
of something stupid that you're doing
that you could quit.
And so that means that you do have this.
It's a strange thing and people that we
have this built in capacity to pause it
a higher self and then to move towards
it and maybe maybe that's part of where
the religious instinct really came from
speaking like really reductionistically
like as a materialist.
As an evolutionary psychologist,
we have this notion of the transcendent
ideal,
right?
That that seems to be pervasive across
cultures.
Well,
maybe that's the ultimate manifestation
of the human proclivity to be able to
pause it an ideal at all and to move
forward.
You pause it.
An ideal,
okay.
That you need that to move forward.
Well,
if you can pause it,
an ideal,
why can't you pause it?
The ultimate ideal?
Well,
if you can then instantly you've got to
religious sensibility instantly and so
maybe that's because I've puzzled like
as a biologist,
what the hell is the basis of the
religious instinct because the idea that
it's mere superstition,
like we can just dispense with that.
That's a wrong.
It's a human universal.
You can evoke religious experiences all
sorts of ways,
so we're not going to play that game.
There's some reason that that instinct
exists and this the first thing to do
with it is to try to reduce it to
something that's biological and leave it
at that.
Not to mess with the metaphysics,
but it certainly could be the case that
it's the ultimate extension of our
capacity to pause it and ideal and we
also might say,
well,
that's good enough because while the
ideal moves you forward,
it fills your life with meaning.
There's no doubt about that because it
is in the movement towards your ideal
that life's meaning is to be attained
and then the question is,
well,
how much meaning is there in moving
forward towards an ultimate ideal?
Well,
more meaning,
even though it's more difficult.
How much?
Well,
that's the open question.